bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va pas
de karl marx marque fait partie de ces
auteurs dont le grand public connaît
bien le nom mais dont on connaît
beaucoup moins bien l'oeuvre marx est
souvent pris à tort pour un homme
politique
mais en réalité il s'agit là d'une très
mauvaise présentation des choses parce
que marx est d'abord un économiste il a
produit une analyse critique de la
société capitaliste
une analyse produite au 19e siècle dont
on continue à se réclamer aujourd'hui et
de nombreux économistes y compris des
économistes libéraux se revendique sans
aucune ambiguïté de son héritage on
citera par exemple jacques attali qui
n'est pas vraiment connu pour ses
positions communiste et qui a consacré
un essai à marx et qui n'hésite pas à
faire savoir toute l'admiration qu'ils
lui vouent marx était un économiste mais
c'était aussi et surtout un philosophe
romandie c'est quelqu'un qui ne
proposait pas seulement une doctrine
mais une vision du monde
philosophe c'est quelqu'un qui propose
une vision du monde et au sein de cette
vision du monde
il y à un concept clé sur lequel on va
se pencher aujourd'hui qu'est le concept
d'aliénation
alors avant de se confronter à ce
concept
je vais prendre un peu d'élan c'est à
dire que je vais commencer par parler
des influences de marx parmi lesquels
son influence principale qui est eagle
comme vous le savez si vous avez regardé
ma précédente vidéo sur la dialectique
eagle s'intéressait beaucoup à
l'histoire
parce que pour lui l'histoire c'était le
lieu de déploiement de la raison
universelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bien ça veut dire qu'il existe une
direction des événements ce qu'on
appellera un sens de l'histoire
je ferai prochainement une vidéo sur le
sens de l'histoire autrement dit
l'histoire ne s'accomplit pas au hasard
l'histoire ne se déroule pas sans une
ligne directrice et lorsque j'en crois
le verbe déroulé vous pouvez imaginer ça
comme un tapis qui est enroulé sur
lui-même et qui lorsqu'on le déroule
déploie ce qu'il était un tapis qui est
enroulé lorsque vous le déroulé vous
n'ajouter rien vous
enlevez rien mais simplement vous
déployer dans l'espace ce que le tapis
est à l'origine est bien la même façon
l'histoire se déroule l'histoire se
déploie et en se déployant elle fait
apparaître ce qui la guide à savoir la
raison c'est en ce sens qu'on parle pour
eagle d'une philosophie idéaliste
idéalisme signifiant que c'est l'esprit
qui conduit la matière la matière n'est
pas un magma chaotique et désorganiser
la matière est quelque chose qui est
organisée et qui se déploient selon une
logique rationnelle
selon la logique de l'esprit alors je
sais que c'est quelque chose qui peut
paraître assez étrange assez abstrait
mais pour l'heure ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que chez hegel
il existe direction des événements et
cette idée là va constituer le socle de
la méthodologie de karl marx à savoir
qu'il existe un sens de l'histoire qui
va s'agir d' identifier pour comprendre
la marche du monde
sauf que contrairement à hegel marx ne
pense pas que l'histoire soit guidé par
un principe spirituel mais au contraire
par un principe matériel et selon marx
ce qui va d'idées l'histoire c'est la
lutte des classes il y à une citation de
marx qui est très explicite dans
laquelle il dit l'histoire humaine et
l'histoire de la lutte des classes
et sur ce plan là il est difficile de
donner tort à marx parce que lorsqu'on
étudie l'histoire on s'aperçoit qu'on
étudie d'abord les conflits s'il n'y
avait pas de conflit s'il n'y avait pas
de guerre il n'y aurait pas d'histoire
parce qu'on aurait rien à raconter et
parce que ce sont les conflits qui sont
à l'origine des évolutions de l'histoire
si tous les peuples se contentait de
vivre paisiblement côte à côte les
civilisations n'aurait aucune raison de
s'auto dépassé en permanence qu'est ce
qui motive la course technologique
qu'est ce qui motive la course militaire
même la course économique
c'est bien cette notion de concurrence
entre les civilisations ou entre les
nations c'est bien cette idée de
compétition qui s'incarne et se traduit
dans le conflit et comme on l'a vu chez
hegel la notion même d'évolution est
conditionnée à l'idée de conflit elle
est conditionnée à l'idée
contradiction un rappelez-vous chez
hegel la conscience ne pas avancer ne
peut progresser que si elle est en
permanence confrontés à la contradiction
c'est à dire à ceux qui n'est pas elle
et c'est dans l'expérience de l'autre
c'est dans l'expérience de la
contradiction que la conscience se
construit que la conscience devient ce
qu'elle est et sans ce rapport à
l'altérité
sans ce rapport à la contradiction le
monde restera figé le monde resterait
statique retrouve andy le conflit est un
moteur eschena rqth le conflit est le
moteur de l'histoire donc la vision de
marx et directement héritée de la vision
des gueules à savoir une vision
conflictuelle de l'histoire pourrait
dire une vision éristique de l'histoire
le mois et ristic renvoyant à l'idée de
disputes de discorde
ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses qu'il y a un rôle positif du
conflit puisque le conflit amène au
surpassement du conflit 1 vous
connaissez ce célèbre adage qui veut la
paix prépare la guerre
là l'idée c'est que pour pouvoir être
dépassé le conflit doit avoir lieu on
peut pas dépasser quelque chose qui
n'existe pas de la façon qu'on ne peut
pas accéder à la vérité sans être
d'abord passer par l'erreur c'est à dire
par le contraire de la vérité
la paix c'est le contraire de la guerre
et pour parvenir à cette paix il faut en
passer par la guerre il faut en passer
par le conflit
c'est ça la notion de dialectique c'est
l'idée que toute chose doit
nécessairement passer par son contraire
par son autre et que c'est seulement une
fois que l'autre a été expérimenté et
digérer qui peut être dépassée et donc
que l'histoire peut s'accomplir jusqu'à
son terme
donc l'histoire humaine est guidé par la
lutte des classes c'est à dire par des
rapports économiques
or qui sont les deux acteurs des
rapports économiques dans l'histoire
et bien selon marx les deux acteurs se
sont les propriétaires et les
prolétaires
on dirait aujourd'hui dans un lexique un
peu moins précis les dominants et les
dominés
et si on disait tout à l'heure que
l'histoire n'existerait pas sans les
guerres et bien on rappellera en même
temps que toute guerre se caractérise
par un vainqueur et un vaincu
autrement dit par un dominant et un
dominé et selon marx la lutte entre ces
deux classes entre la classe des
propriétaires la classe des prolétaires
c'est ce qui détermine le devenir du
monde et quand je dis détermine faut
bien prendre la mesure de ce que
signifie ce mot c'est à dire qu'il
n'existe pas de hasard mais au contraire
une loi de nécessité comme chez google
d'ailleurs là encore donc la dialectique
hégélienne était basé sur l'idée que
l'esprit détermine la matière alors
qu'au contraire la dialectique marxienne
va être basé sur l'idée que c'est la
matière qui détermine l'esprit c'est ce
qui fait qu'on parle de dialectique
matérialiste ou encore de matérialisme
historique pour qualifier la vision du
monde de marx à savoir que selon marx il
n'existe pas au dessus du monde
un esprit qui guide le monde le monde
n'est pas la projection mobile d'une
réalité spirituelle qui trônerait au
dessus de lui le monde est au contraire
ce qui va générer l'esprit ce qui va
générer la raison ce qui va générer la
conscience d'ailleurs lorsque l'on veut
expliquer la différence entre marc segel
on parle de renversement matérialiste
par marx de la philosophie hégélienne
autrement dit au conserve le principe de
la dialectique qui consiste à dire que
tout ce qui a lieu est le produit d'une
évolution d'un processus conflictuel
mais en revanche là où chez hegel c'est
l'idée qui guident et la matière chez
marx c'est la matière qui guide les
idées alors il ya une phrase de marx qui
résume parfaitement cette idée qui dit
ce n'est pas la conscience des hommes
qui détermine leur être c'est au
contraire leur être social qui détermine
leur conscience alors ça y est une
manière très simple de le résumer ça
pourrait être nous avons les idées de
notre situation matérielle nous avons
les idées de notre situation matérielle
autrement dit notre conscience c'est le
produit de notre vécu
c'est le produit de notre rapport
matériel au monde
selon l'environnement dans lequel vous
aurez grandi selon votre milieu social
d'origine selon votre éducation
vous n'aurez pas les mêmes idées vous
n'aurez pas la même conscience parce que
votre conscience sera construit
différemment
dès lors que notre conscience se
construit à travers les influences
qu'elle reçoit bien il est évident qu'à
un vécu différent va correspondre une
conscience différentes
regardez comme il est parfois difficile
de s'entendre avec des personnes qui
n'ont pas du tout le même vécu on a
l'impression parfois qu'on parle avec
quelqu'un qui n'a pas du tout les mêmes
codes les mêmes références et ce
différentiel au niveau des codes au
niveau des références et bien il n'est
pas seulement liée à une conformation
différente de notre esprit à la
naissance
ça peut arriver qu'il y ait des
différences de mentalité qui soit il est
mais le plus souvent c'est le décalage
dans le vécu c'est à dire dans la
situation matérielle dans le rapport
concret au monde qui va créer ensuite
des écarts dans la pensée des écarts
dans les consciences et pour peu que
vous ayez eu des expériences extrêmement
différentes voire opposées les unes aux
autres qu'à ce moment là vous pouvez
être sûr que l'incompréhension risque de
se glisser dans votre dialogue
c'est tout à fait normal et c'est
d'ailleurs ce à la fonction de la
rencontre et de l'interaction avec
l'autre c'est d'élargir son champ de
conscience au contact d'une expérience
qui n'est pas la nôtre on peut apprendre
qu'au contact de quelqu'un qui a eu
d'autres expériences
donc si la conscience est tout entière
déterminée par des rapports matériel et
chez marx rapport matériel ça signifie
des rapports économiques aux socios et
bien ça une conséquences extrêmement
lourdes
la conséquence de tout ça s'il n'y a pas
de liberté
pourquoi ça signifie qu'il n'ya pas
liberté et bien si nous sommes
entièrement déterminé par notre
situation matérielle
cela signifie que c'est notre situation
matérielle qui fait de nous ce que nous
sommes et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
faire de nous ce que nous sommes et là
ça veut dire nous conditionner à penser
de telle ou telle manière
c'est ça que ça veut dire notre
situation matérielle nous conditionne à
penser de telle ou telle manière
et parce qu un vécu différent 28 rue
mentalités différentes conceptions du
monde différente bien l'idée c'est que
la conscience est intégralement le fruit
de cette situation matérielle
donc je disais qu'il n'y a pas de
liberté chez marx précisément parce que
la liberté c'est la capacité à
s'autodéterminer dans sa conscience la
liberté c'est la capacité de s'arracher
au déterminisme qui nous conditionnent
parce que si toutes vos pensées sont
guidés par votre vécu et si ce vécu est
lui-même le produit d'un déterminisme
auquel vous ne pouvez pas échapper bien
ça signifie en bout de chaîne que vous
ne pouvez pas penser autrement que de la
manière dont vous pensez
et ça c'est précisément le contraire de
la liberté la liberté en tant que
pouvoir d'arrachement au déterminisme de
cette liberté pour marx n'existe pas
donc retenez cette idée vraiment très
importante pour comprendre le concept
d'aliénation chez marx c'est que selon
la vision du monde de marx toutes nos
idées sur le fruit de notre condition
matérielle et donc en tant que tel notre
conscience n'est pas libre entre
conscience et déterminé déterminé par
les rapports socio économique déterminée
par les rapports matériel déterminé par
le devenir historique
alors qu'est ce qui pose problème dans
cette conception marxienne de la liberté
et bien c'est tout simplement le fait
que cette vision déterministe qui
conduit à l'absence de liberté humaine
bien cette idée va totalement en
contradiction avec le sentiment de
liberté que nous éprouvons avec la
croyance en notre liberté que nous
présupposons parce qu'on est bien
l'accord que même si on adopte une
conception du monde déterministe au
quotidien nous agissons en être libres
nous agissons comme si nous étions bien
les maîtres de nos choix
si vous allez faire vos courses au
supermarché et que quelqu'un vient
remplir votre caddie avec des produits
que vous n'avez pas choisi
on est bien d'accord que ces produits
vous allez pas les payer à la caisse
vous allez les remettre dans le rayon où
vous allez abandonner votre caddie dans
le supermarché mais en tout cas vous
n'allez pas vous laisser imposer de
l'extérieur une volonté qui n'est pas la
vôtre pas vous soumettre l conscience
qui n'est pas la vôtre
et c'est là qu'on rentre véritablement
dans le coeur de ce concept d'aliénation
alors déjà il faut préciser que
aliénation étymologiquement ça vient de
alien qui signifie autre d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas un hasard si en anglais le mot
aliens signifie extraterrestres ou en
tout cas un être venu d'ailleurs puisque
précisément aliens signifie autre et
donc est ce que c'est que l'aliénation
et bien l'aliénation c'est le processus
par lequel un autre que soi prend le
contrôle de notre conscience
autrement dit l'aliénation c'est la
dépossession de ce qui fait notre
humanité à savoir notre conscience alors
pour vous illustrer ce concept
d'aliénation et pour rester dans la
sphère de réflexion marxienne je vais
prendre un exemple qui va être un
dialogue imaginaire entre un travailleur
libéral et un travailleur salarié
puisque d'ailleurs il a beaucoup de
points communs en réalité entre les
libéraux honnête et les marxistes
honnête point de vue de leur grille de
lecture du monde
alors imaginons un libéral qui dirait à
son amie salariée
quand tu travailles tu ne travailles pas
pour toi tu travailles canton patron cas
pour le propriétaire son être précis
quand tu travailles tu vends à force de
travail à ton patron 1 c'est pierre
bergé qui disait louer ses bras ou louer
son ventre la différence donc tu vends à
force de travail contre un salaire c'est
à dire contre un moyen de subsistance
ça veut dire quoi là ça veut dire que le
produit de ton travail ne t'appartient
pas de produits ton travail appartient
au propriétaire le profit réalisé grâce
à ton travail
il part dans les poches du propriétaire
ce que marx appelait l'extorsion la plus
value c'est à dire la production d'une
valeur ajoutée par le travail du
prolétaire qui se retrouvent dans la
poche du propriétaire en contrepartie
d'un salaire ça c'est le principe même
de l'exploitation je rappelle que
exploitation c'est un terme objectif
quand on exploite une situation quand on
exploite des ressources
ça veut dire qu'on les utilise pour les
mettre à notre profit est d'ailleurs le
simple mode employé quand
dit je suis employé dans une entreprise
employés ça signifie utiliser ce qui
indique bien ce processus de réification
c'est-à-dire de réduction à l'état
d'objet du travailleur un employeur
c'est quelqu'un qui emploie c'est
quelqu'un qui utilise à son profit est
donc là on a la réponse du salarié qui
va être de dire oui mais tu comprends ça
me permet quand même de vivre ça me
permet quand même de payer mes factures
de payer des vêtements mes enfants de
remplir mon frigo et puis bon tu sais
mon patron ça va il est sympa et alors
là on est en plein dans ce que marx
appelle l'aliénation c'est-à-dire
l'intériorisation par le prolétaire de
la volonté et du propriétaire
c'est l'acceptation d'une situation
objectivement déséquilibré alors je ne
dis pas un justin cesser de parler en
termes objectif mais d'une situation
objectivement déséquilibré c'est à dire
qu'au lieu de considérer sa perte dans
cette histoire est le fait que sans lui
le propriétaire ne serait pas dans une
position de supériorité économico
sociale au lieu de considérer ça le
travailleur va considérer ce qui le
rattache à sa condition
ce qui le maintient dans sa condition ce
qui le verrouille dans sa position
d'exploiter et ça c'est exactement ce
que souhaite le propriétaire parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'exploitation sans le
consentement de l'exploiter il n'ya pas
d'exploitation sans l'acceptation de
l'exploitation
et attention c'est tout à fait normal il
n'y a pas de jugement de valeur dans
cette analyse de max ya pas de jugement
de valeur il n'y a pas de
disqualification du comportement du
travailleur puisque le travailleur c'est
précisément celui qui subissent cette
situation mais il s'agit simplement de
décrire un mécanisme mécanisme général
qui comporte une dimension psychologique
est le produit du travailleur se défend
totalement c'est de dire
déjà il faut bien bouffer 1 il ya un
impératif de survie qui commandent nos
actes et donc la conscience qui
découlent de ses actes donc il faut bien
trouver un chemin psychologique qui
conduit à l'acceptation de notre
situation
et puis il ya aussi l'idée que comme m
qu'on est un esclave
comment admettre qu'on est un esclave et
bien cette question elle résume à elle
seule le principe de l'aliénation
on ne peut pas accepter d'être un
esclave quand je dis qu'on peut pas
l'accepter je veux dire qu'on peut pas y
consentir consciemment
on est toujours obligé de justifier
intellectuellement une situation
matérielle qu'on n'a pas choisi on
obligeait de trouver un sens là dedans
alors attention parfois il peut très
bien y avoir un sens toujours y avoir
une explication rationnelle à une
situation qu'on n'a pas choisi
c'est vrai mais l'aliénation ça va plus
loin
l'aliénation c'est l'intériorisation en
soi de la volonté d'autrui c'est le
remplacement de sa propre conscience par
la conscience de l'autre
donc on est au delà de la simple
explication rationnelle de la situation
on est au delà de la simple recherche de
cause on est dans la légitimation voir
dans l'adhésion ça ça va beaucoup plus
loin a prouvé sa propre soumission à
prouver sa propre servitude comme le
disait labo ici c'est se rendre
responsable de sa servitude responsables
non pas à l'échelle individuelle
né à l'échelle collective est ici qu'on
soit bien d'accord on ne parle pas d'une
conscience de l'autre qui serait un
apport pour notre propre conscience
on parle pas d'un sens positive qui
serait la rencontre d'une altérité qui
nous permettrait d'augmenter notre
propre champ de conscience là celle
inverse par l'aliénation nous
n'augmentons pas notre champ de
conscience nous le réduisons nous
l'anéantît sont ce que veut dire marx
c'est que par l'aliénation
nous jouons contre nos propres intérêts
l'aliénation sait jouer contre ses
intérêts et donc vous le voyez ce
concept d'aliénation il remet
complètement en cause le concept de
liberté puisque la liberté présuppose
une conscience active non pas une
conscience passive non pas une
conscience soumise mais il remet même en
cause la notion même de consentement
parce que la notion de consentement ne
prend pas en compte cette idée
d'aliénation la notion de consentement
ne prend pas en compte le fait que notre
conscience puisse être aliénés à la
conscience d'autrui
or que vous un consentement quand notre
conscience et téléguidée par la
conscience d'autrui
ce serait comme de faire signer à
quelqu'un son testament après l'avoir
fait boire ou après l'avoir droguée ou
peu importe
lorsque vous provoquer une altération
l'état de conscience on est bien
d'accord que la personne n'est plus
maître de ses décisions
vous avez aliéner sa conscience pour la
diriger dans le sens de vos propres
intérêts et bien ce que veut dire marx
c'est qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir bu
ou d'avoir pris de la drogue pour que
notre conscience soit aliéné
il suffit d'avoir créé les conditions
objectives dans lesquelles nous allons
nous aliéner nous mêmes à la conscience
de l'autre pour justifier notre
situation matérielle un salarié va se
considérer comme dépendant de son patron
comme dépendant de son entreprise et du
propriétaire de cette entreprise
partant de là il va trouver tous les
chemins pour justifier sa situation
d'exploiter et surtout ne jamais la
remettre en cause
jamais chercher à s'y opposer parce
qu'en s'y opposant la conscience qu'ils
risquent de perdre cette situation cette
situation qui dès lors lui apparaît
presque comme un privilège vous rendez
compte c'est à dire que la peur de
perdre notre moyen de subsistance peut
nous conduire à nous considérer comme
des privilégiés alors même que nous
sommes les exploiter c'est quand même
incroyable c'est être incroyable selon
marx c'est ça qui guide les rapports
sociaux
les rapports économiques c'est ça qui
guident l'histoire des hommes c'est très
important de comprendre cette idée qui
est que l'aliénation c'est un
conditionnement telle qu'on ne se rend
même pas compte qu'on est aliénée et
sympa qu'on ne se rend même pas compte
c'est qu'on envisage même pas l'idée
il ne vient même pas à l'esprit que l'on
puisse être aliénés parce que dès lors
qu'on se pose la question notre
aliénation sait déjà qu'on est en train
de sortir de l'aliénation la remise en
question l'auto examen
ce sont déjà des indicateurs de la
sortie de l'aliénation et on le voit
très bien dans le roman de george orwell
dès lors que vous n'avez plus les mots
pour penser votre condition mais ça veut
dire que votre condition
ne vous appartient plus ça veut dire que
vous n'êtes qu'une maître de votre
destin
donc je disais l'aliénation c'est un
conditionnement telle qu'on ne s'en rend
même pas compte
et pour l'illustrer je vais prendre un
exemple un peu hardcore pardonner
l'anglicisme prenons l'exemple d'un
nouveau né qui grandiraient dans une
famille qui le maltraitent qui le fait
travailler qui le livrent aux prédations
imaginé cet enfant qui grandit dans cet
environnement dans ce conditionnement et
qui ne saurait absolument rien de ce qui
se passe dans les autres maisons dans
les autres familles et bien si cet
enfant ne connais pas d'autres modèles
que celui dans lequel ils évoluent
qu'est ce qui va se passer
il va trouver ça normal il va trouver ça
normal parce qu'il n'aura pas d'autres
repères parce qu'il n'aura pas d'autres
référentiels qui va un moment donné lui
faire se poser la question
il a un moment donné lui faire remettre
en cause sa propre norme c'est ça le
propre d'une conscience qui trouve que
tout est normal
c'est qu'elle se pose pas la question de
la normalité ou pas du schéma dans
lequel elle évolue trouver quelque chose
normale c'est précisément ne pas se
poser la question de sa normalité et
bien l'aliéner c'est celui qui ne se
pose pas la question de son aliénation
ne se pose pas la question de sa
servitude et qui d'une certaine manière
ne comprend même pas où est le problème
c'est peut-être ça l'homme le plus
terrible dans l'aliénation et d'oran les
conséquences qu'elle peut avoir c'est
cette acceptation produite par le
sentiment de normalité
or qu'est ce que le sentiment de
normalité c'est l'adaptation c'est
l'habitude parce qu'une chose se répète
un certain nombre de fois elle finit par
devenir une habitude et quand cette
habitude elle même se répète
elle devient la normalité c'est ça
l'aliénation de la conscience c'est la
privation des moyens de réflexion sur sa
propre condition c'est la privation des
moyens d'avoir conscience de sa
servitude
il voyait que dans ce schéma de
l'aliénation
il n'est nul besoin de recourir à la
contrainte physique je dis souvent un
totalitarisme matures c'est un
totalitarisme qui n'a plus besoin de
forcer les individus n'a plus besoin de
contraindre les corps vous avez encore
aujourd'hui des totalitarismes non
aboutie des totalitarismes qui ne sont
pas encore parvenus à ce stade de
l'aliénation des consciences et dans
lesquelles il est encore nécessaire de
contraindre par la force par la violence
par l'intimidation les individus à se
comporter de telle ou telle manière
mais plus vous allez contraindre
physiquement quelqu'un à faire quelque
chose plus vous allez lui donner les
moyens de se rendre compte de sa
condition de dominer
alors que lorsque vous travaillez
directement à la source c'est-à-dire
lorsque vous faites en sorte que la
conscience de celui que vous exploitez
soit consentante à cette exploitation
vous n'avez plus besoin de contraindre
les corps et à ce moment là vous pourrez
toujours justifier votre situation de
domination par le consentement du dominé
dès lors que vous avez aliéner la
conscience d'autrui à vos propres
intérêts et à votre propre volonté
vous n'avez plus à craindre la révolte
vous avez fait de votre esclave votre
allié tenir à prendre un autre exemple
pour détendre un peu l'atmosphère
c'est l'exemple de la pièce de molière
l'école des femmes dans l'école des
femmes vous avez un personnage qui
s'appelle arnolphe qui est un homme
d'âge assez mûrs assez avancée et qui
voudraient se marier mais le problème
c'est que il a une peur panique d'être
cocu la peur panique que sa femme le
trompe et donc pour pour parer à cette
situation il a décidé d'épouser sa fille
adoptive sa pupille s'appelle agnès et
pour sam
eh bien il a volontairement élevés dans
l'ignorance des choses de l'amour et
même dans l'ignorance du monde extérieur
ou cour pour qu'elle ne soit pas soumise
à la tentation
donc il s'est livré à une véritable
entreprise d'aliénation mentale de
conditionnement domestique
c'est à dire qu'il a créé
l'environnement qui va faire qu'agnès ne
sera même pas en mesure d'envisager
l'infidélité
parce que comme je le disais 'si vous
attaquer directement à la mentalité de
celui que vous voulez vous aliéner à ce
moment là vous n'avez plus besoin de
contrôler ses faits et gestes
vous n'avez plus besoin de contraindre
son corps il le fera de lui-même il le
fera sans se poser la question et c'est
ce qu'on fait avec un animal domestique
en l'adresse est donc un bon dressage
ça consiste à créer les conditions dans
lesquelles les esclaves ne va même pas
se poser la question de son esclavage
l'esclave obéissant c'est celui dont les
chaînes sont invisibles
et donc arnolphe il sait que si l'on n'a
pas conscience de l'existence d'une
chose on peux pas l'envisager
donc ils pensent que en privant agnès de
tout contact avec les hommes de tout
contact avec le monde extérieur
il va en faire une épouse fidèle il
épouse qui ne regardera pas les autres
sommes tout simplement parce qu'elle
n'enverra pas bon ben il se trouve que
ça marche pas puisque agnès va tomber
amoureuse de horace ce qui veut bien
dire qu'il aura fallu une intervention
extérieure pour qu'agnès puisse sortir
de son aliénation sortir de l'aliénation
ça nécessite une intervention extérieure
quelle qu'elle soit parce qu'on ne s'en
rend pas compte
ou plutôt c'est pas qu'on s'en rend pas
compte c'est qu'on est programmé pour
consentir à la situation et être
programmé pour consentir une situation
ça montre bien aussi que la notion de
consentement est parfois insuffisante
voire que le consentement peut être
utilisé comme un instrument de
domination
à ce propos je vous renvoie au livre de
edward bernays propagande a sous titré
comment manipuler l'opinion démocratie
qui montre que si on veut manipuler une
population il faut pas la contraindre il
ne faut pas la contredire
au contraire il faut obtenir son
consentement consentement à la guerre le
consentement à son exploitation
consentement aux lois 1 c'est le
principe de toute élection
quand on a voté pour quelqu'un on a
consenti en a validé en acier et donc si
on a signé on est engagé on est lié par
un contrat
l'anneau son contrat repose sur le
consentement et en même temps un contrat
c'est ce qui vous lie c'est ce qui vous
oblige au sens juridique du terme et
dans une société de la sacralisation du
désir individuel il est très facile
du point de vue de la chine et les
social il est très facile de manipuler
les consciences dans le sens des
intérêts du pouvoir avoir une influence
de la mode la mode étant d'abord une
création économique donc l'aliénation
c'est le processus par lequel je me fais
des valises et de ma propre conscience
au profit d'une autre conscience autre
conscience qui luttent non pas pour mes
intérêts mais pour ses intérêts le
propre de l'allier naters et qu ils
prétendre à toujours défendre vos
intérêts
il prétendra toujours savoir ce qui est
bon pour vous ça ne veut pas dire que
toute personne qui veut faire quelque
chose de bon pour vous weil vous aliéner
mais ça veut dire que toute personne qui
va vouloir vous aliéner le fera toujours
au nom de vos intérêts et c'est en ce
sens que l'aliénation
c'est le plus puissant des processus de
déshumanisation parce qu'il repose
entièrement sur la falsification de ce
qui fait l'essence de l'humanité à
savoir sa conscience et dans l'analyse
de marx
l'ouvrier devient plus aliénés à mesure
qu'ils créent de la marchandise c'est à
dire à mesure qu'il est investi dans le
processus économique dans le processus
marchon plus il participe activement au
processus économique c'est-à-dire à une
situation dans laquelle il est
objectivement exploiter et plus il est
aliéné en psychologie
on appelle ça l'escaladent de
l'engagement plus vous êtes engagés dans
un processus est plus devient difficile
de vous en retirez ce qui est logique
c'est logique mais il ya quand même une
différence entre avoir du mal à se
désengager d'une situation et consentir
à cette situation la considérer comme
normal voir là considérée comme
bénéfique pour nous là ça va beaucoup
plus loin
et pour illustrer cette idée on peut
penser à ce qu'on trouve beaucoup aux
états unis l'employé du moins l'employé
du moins dans une vision marxienne
celles exploitées qui est fier d'être
exploitée il est fier d'être l'exploiter
du moins alors on lui donne une médaille
puis on affiche sa tête dans les
couloirs il est content c'est vraiment
ça l'aliénation moderne nous rendre
fiers de notre exploitation et tous ceux
qui ont fait un peu de management savent
très bien que le principe de l'autonomie
des employés qui fait qu'on va donner à
des employés des tâches des
responsabilités pour les impliquer dans
la vie de l'entreprise
mais à tout ça ça participe activement
au processus de l'aliénation la
dépossession de notre conscience par une
conscience qui a d'autres intérêts
et donc l'ouvrier va devenir un pur
objet un pur instrument et plus ils
créent la marchandise
autrement dit puis il produit des forts
et plus il devient lui-même marchandises
et quel est le propre d'une marchandise
bien c'est qu'elle est monnayable
elle est interchangeable les
mobilisables jetables donc on va
remplacer un travailleur qualifié mais
pas assez soumis par un autre
travailleur qui sera peut-être moins
qualifiés mais qui sera plus docile qui
sera moins regardant sur ses intérêts et
ce faisant on élimine de la grande
machine économique
les éléments perturbateurs on élimine
tout ce qui pourrait faire croître les
germes de la conscience dans un système
de plus en plus automatisés ou
l'intelligence est devenu le contraire
de la pensée alors s'il fallait malgré
tout finir sur une note optimiste je
dirais que nous sommes tous encore
individuellement et collectivement les
dépositaires de la conscience humaine
sur terre et si la lutte pour la
conscience précède toutes les autres
luttes
si la lutte pour la conscience et la
seule qu'il nous est impardonnable de ne
pas mener
n'oublions pas qu'il s'agit d'abord
d'une minute contre nous-mêmes d'une
lutte contre ce qui nous empêche d'y
voir clair d'une lutte contre ce qui en
nous joue contre nous
je vous remercie
[Musique]